Narrator: IN A LAST-DITCH
ATTEMPT TO BUST OUT OF JAIL,
ADAM AND JAMIE UNLEASH
THE SUPPOSEDLY AWESOME POWER
OF ANTACID --
SOME IN TABLET FORM,
AND SOME AS RAW INGREDIENTS.
THEY START BY DRENCHING JUST THE
PILL PILE WITH THE SMALL HOSE.
THIS IS PHASE ONE.
PRESSURE IS STILL INCREASING
ON THE PLASTIC.
I CAN SEE IT MOVING.
REALLY?
YEAH.
RIGHT IN THE CORNER
DOWN THERE.
Narrator: EVEN BETTER,
ADAM'S GAUGE CLUSTER
IS FINALLY
FEELING THE PRESSURE.
OH, WE'RE GETTING SOMETHING
ON THE NEEDLE.
JUST A TINY BIT.
GOT MAYBE 20% OF 1 PSI.
WE'VE PROBABLY
TAKEN CARE
OF MORE THAN HALF
OF THE ANTACID TABLETS THERE --
14,000, 15,000
AT THIS POINT.
AM I CRAZY,
OR DOES THAT DOOR SEEM LIKE
IT'S PUSHING OUT ON THE BOTTOM?
IT IS.
IS IT?
LOOK ALONG THE RAIL
ON THE BOTTOM.
THE DOOR IS PRESSING OUT
ON THE TOP AND THE BOTTOM.
WE'RE AT JUST A HAIR'S BREATH
UNDER 1/2 OF A PSI.
YEAH, THE PILE
IS ALMOST ENTIRELY WET.
FOAM HAS CRAWLED
ALL THE WAY UP IT.
I DON'T KNOW, DUDE.
YOU WANT TO DO WHAT WE DO BEST?
YOU WANT TO TAKE IT
TO THE NEXT LEVEL?
YEAH, OVER THE TOP.
CUE THE DELUGE.
LET'S GO TO PHASE TWO --
TURN EVERYTHING UP TO FULL.
PHASE TWO IS THE TUB
AND THE FIRE HOSE.
IF IT DOES WHAT IT SHOULD,
WE'RE JUST MOMENTS AWAY
FROM THE WORLD'S BIGGEST BELCH.
THERE WE GO.
WATER IS POURING
INTO OUR TUB.
OKAY.
OH, WE'RE AT 1 PSI!
IT'S CLIMBING
LIKE A ROCKET.
1.5 PSI.
LOOK AT THE DOOR!
EYES OPEN!
2 PSI!
THE DOOR IS GONNA GO.
2.5 PSI!
OH, MY GOD!
WE'RE COMING UP
TO 4 PSI.
AND THE DOOR IS -- OH!
OH, MY GOD.
IS EVERYONE OKAY?
OH.
IT ACTUALLY WORKED.
DUDE!
[ LAUGHS ]
LOOK AT THAT.
Jamie: YOU COULD HEAR IT,
AND WITHIN SECONDS,
THE DOOR STARTED TO POTATO CHIP.
THIS MASSIVE DOOR THAT I BUILT
IS JUST, LIKE, CREAKING
AND GROANING AND CURLING
FROM ALL OF THIS PRESSURE.
IT WAS AGONIZING TO WATCH IT.